it is an historic week for China where
president Xi Jinping is tightening his
grip on power at the Communist party's
National Congress president XI has
introduced more assertive policies at
home and abroad leading to some chilly
relations with neighboring Taiwan in
tighter controls over Hong Kong that
city has seen major upheaval in recent
years where the police Crackdown on
pro-democracy protesters Elizabeth
Palmer is there with more on this part
of the story Liz good morning to you
good morning not so long ago Hong Kong
was a British territory and as such it
had a vibrant civil society and media
that one high-profile recent legal case
shows just how much that's changed
this hooded prisoner's crime was
publishing three children's books about
a village full of sheep the books were
seized by Hong Kong police as evidence
of Believe It or Not sedition some of
the material inside which is with a
seditious intent which bring the hatreds
against the government Hong Kong used to
have some of the liveliest freest speech
in the world until China took over and
in 2020 imposed the national security
law that in effect bans all criticism of
beijing's policies and its governance
soon after pro-democracy protests
erupted in 2019 the Hong Kong government
under Chinese pressure moved to shut
down almost all independent news outlets
including the respected Apple Daily
newspaper
whose senior staff were sent to jail
and when Hong Kong's huge book fair
returned in 2021 as the pandemic ebbed
it looked like business as usual but a
year later any political book with Edge
was gone
Keith Richburg is the head of Journalism
at Hong Kong University they don't want
journalism to be a check on government
they don't want anyone to be a check on
government how
severe are the penalties for those who
have crossed the red line penalties can
range up to life in prison you know so
life in prison no possibility of parole
you can't really defend yourself against
these things
did try to defend themselves their
lawyers argued the books would help kids
understand systemic Injustice but
authorities recognized the Sheep as not
so thinly disguised pro-democracy Hong
kongers and the predatory wolves you
guessed it the Chinese
a definite Red Line the sentence for
each of the Publishers just over a year
and a half in jail
as we worked on this story I was struck
by how many people would talk to us but
not on camera that includes lawyers
activists and Publishers there's a chill
in the air and anyone who's critical is
keeping a very low profile Tony
I don't understand why Liz Palmer for us
in Hong Kong Liz thank you very much